we begin with this or new signs of an
intensifying standoff between President
Trump and the special counsel in the
Russia investigation the Washington Post
says Robert Muller has told the
president's lawyer that mr. Trump might
be subpoenaed if he does not agree to
answer investigators questions Jeff
Piquet's is outside the special
counsel's office in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning after 19
indictments it doesn't look like a
Russia investigation will end without
robert muller questioning the president
at least that's what the special counsel
is signaling the ongoing negotiations
with the president's legal team have
become contentious and it is unclear
what will come next in January President
Trump told reporters he was interested
in talking with Special Counsel Robert
Muller under oath I would love to do
that behind the scenes the president's
lawyers have been carefully negotiating
the terms of those possible talks in one
meeting with Muller according to the
Washington Post the lawyers insisted the
President had no obligation to talk
Muller responded that he could issue a
subpoena for the president to appear
before a grand jury the episode
highlights the escalating showdown
between the White House and the special
counsel Harry Lippmann is a former
official at the Department of Justice
the bare minimum for Muller is going to
be to get some answers from Trump under
oath no prosecutor would settle for less
and any answers under oath by Trump puts
him in serious criminal jeopardy
Republicans are also taking aim at
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
who oversees Muller's investigation but
I can tell you there were people who
have been making threats privately and
publicly against me for quite some time
yesterday Rosen Stein pushed back
against reports that Republican
lawmakers were drafting articles of
impeachment against him
Republican members of the house freedom
caucus say impeachment would be used
against Rosenstein as a last resort if
he doesn't comply with requests for
information pertaining to the Russia
investigation
I think they should understand by now
the Department of Justice is not going
to be extorted
a subpoena has always been an option for
the Special Counsel to use but to use it
to compel a president to testify well
that's something that could lead to a
legal battle in the Supreme Court the
special counsel's office is not
commenting nor is the president's legal
team beyond Oh fascinating to hear from
Rosenstein as well Jeff thank you